foreign
[Music]
this is my secret so my great uncle's
daughter's ex-husband killed my great
uncle and the ex-husband has been on the
run ever since and it's been like three
years
I plan on moving away and telling nobody
every time someone's ever tried to stop
me I've listened I've decided I'm not
going to listen anymore
I have a bacterial growth in my armpits
that cause them caused my hairs to turn
neon orange
trying to be happy today it's kind of
hard just because the family problems I
have and I just wish that um everyone
going through hard times can stay strong
if you have family problems you never
alone
foreign
[Music]